hi this is luca from lucalampedal.com
and today i'm going to talk to you about
real versus fake polygons recently i
made a video about
criticism of language writing about the
fact that a lot of people content
creators or normal youtubers or people
who expose themselves speaking showcases
their language skills get a lot of flack
or criticism or negative criticisms
and address the problem of how to
fundamentally face it
but the interesting fact about that
video is that quite a few comments
pointed to the fact
that um a lot of hatred or a lot of
misunderstandings come from the fact
that there are
some so-called pseudo-polyglots who
demand that they speak
many more languages than they actually
can or they just demand that they speak
the languages when in fact they mutter a
couple of sentences then they have
a very superficial smattering of the
languages that they claim to speak
before we delve into the fake versus
real
polygon controversy let me address the
problem of what it constitutes what it
means to be
a polyglot now the word polyglot the
word
speak the the concept of speaking a
language or a fluency are kind of vague
and
up to discussion already talked about it
in numerous videos
if you want to check the last video i
made about fluency please check
and on and click on the link in the
description box but in general i would
say that we need a starting we need a
point of reference
and again this is my humble opinion and
this is um
what i think constitutes a polyglot to
me a
polyglot meaning from the greek word
poli glosses los alases many languages
for me a polyglot is a person who speaks
at least
three foreign languages other than their
own and
when it comes to speaking i mean
speaking fluently and again for me
fluency means
at least a b2 level being able to
understand being able to function in a
society understand what is being said
to them as well as getting their point
across in a smooth way
albeit you know with mistakes
so with that point of reference how do
you judge a polyglot well even if we
have this point of reference
it's kind of difficult to judge to
really being able to gauge
a polyget scale unless you're a polygon
unless you speak those languages
and it's difficult in general because we
have for example
the cefr framework of
reference european framework of
reference for a language acquisition and
skills
that detail the various skills that you
have to
have in order to pass certain exams
ranging from a1
to c2 so you have six levels but in my
experience
even then when you pass an exam it
doesn't necessarily mean
that you have that level you can prepare
specifically for that exam
and pass it and sometimes native
speakers
would have a hard time passing that exam
because
of the form of the exam itself
so these exams are a little bit
indicative of one's skills
but they're not the ultimate proof i
myself
have four c2 certificates but again
this doesn't mean much i prepared for
the exams and i passed these exams
i think their real life circumstances
and experience are much more
valuable and with that in mind
i would say in general that it's kind of
difficult
to judge whether a polyglot is a real
polyglot or not
but even then i think the point is moot
i think the point is not
that important whether you can tell if a
person is a real polyglot or not because
people have different skill sets motives
reasons
purposes in life i remember i once
talked in berlin to anthony mativier
who is a memory guru and i asked him
point black what's the point of
memorizing an entire deck of cards and
memorizing things the way you do and he
said
why not like what about people wanting
to climb mount everest
they have a purpose that you might
understand but it's a purpose that they
have
so in the case in the realm of
the online polyglots who
you know run around walk-in malls or do
pranks
surprise people you have all sorts of
people out there who like doing
engaging in all sorts of different
things the real point that you have to
ask yourself
the real question is what do i get out
of this so
you have possibly two paths that you can
follow either you can follow the path of
misunderstanding
hate and squandering a lot of your time
and energy and to try and understand
without understanding and trying to
criticize
and blame and negativity brings more
negative
negativity or you can follow the path of
trying to understand and try to get
something positive
out of it now recently i've been reading
this
book this the daily stoic uh 366
meditations and wisdom perseverance and
the art
of living by ryan holiday and i wanted
to read a passage to you
so every day this book is really
interesting because every day there is a
lesson
to learn and this is june
24th and let me read this passage to you
socrates famously traveled around athens
approaching the people he disagreed with
most and engaging them in long
discussions
and these discussions or what record we
have of them
there are many examples of his
conversation mates getting exasperated
upset or aggravated by his many
questions
indeed the people of athens eventually
got so upset
they sentenced socrates to death but
socrates never seemed to get upset
himself
even when talking about matters of life
and death he always kept his cool
he was much more interested in hearing
what the other person had to say than
making sure he was heard of
as most of us insist upon winning the
argument
the next time you face a political
dispute or a personal disagreement
ask yourself is there any reason to
fight about this
is arguing going to help solve anything
would an educated or wise person really
be as quarrelsome as you might initially
be inclined be inclined to be
or would they take a breath relax and
resist a temptation for conflict
just think of what you could accomplish
and how much better you would feel
if you could conquer the need to fight
and win
every tiny little thing so the point for
me is that whenever
i personally watch videos that happened
at the beginning that has been happening
over the last 10 years because
you know the internet has changed
youtube has changed
a lot of people have been doing a lot of
different things in the realm of
language learning
at first i did not understand that was
far from my philosophy my philosophy is
for example when it comes to
acquiring a lot of languages is to speak
languages extremely well and get to the
point where
i can use the language and benefit uh
from the language
enjoy the language in every situation
but i do understand and i've realized
now that there are p
other people who have different motives
a different stand a different philosophy
different life circumstances and it's
not up to me
to judge what i can do is when i watch
certain videos is what can i get and you
can do that too what can i get what
positive aspects can i get from these
videos maybe a person who runs and
does pranks or talks to people on the
street
well i have it's not my style but i do
recognize that that's a very cool form
of entertainment that i could do myself
so that
i always take note take notes and and
then try to get inspired by that and say
okay
this guy does something that i haven't
done yet or that i have a hard time
doing
what can i learn or people in you know
approaching
people in general on the street asking
questions and uh
you know learning and interacting and
getting in the realm of the
i'd say out of their comfort zone in a
way i would not i haven't done that i
would not do that but i do recognize
that there's some value of that or some
people who want to learn
or an enormous amount of languages maybe
just barely scratching the surface and
learning a smattering of each language
but that's totally fine
so i think it's up to you to decide what
you can make
out of this you can blame criticize and
misunderstand
and waste a lot of time and remember
nothing's gonna change
because you might think oh i'm gonna
expose that guy but think about the time
you spent and the energy you've spent
and think about the consequences has
anything
changed so far i don't think that
blaming and criticizing can
actually change things or you can just
ask yourself what is it that i admire of
this person try to find something
because i
i think at the end of the day everybody
has
something to offer and that's uh the
very uh
that's the at the core of this video
so just to just to recap i want to say
that in general
there are people on youtube who showcase
their language skills and
most often than not they have a
superficial smattering
of a lot of languages but
in order to judge a polyglot you need to
be a multilingual person
you need to spend a lot of time with
these people which is not realistic and
not possible
and even if they claimed
that they have cfr exams it's still a
just a partial acknowledgement of their
skills
but the real point is does it really
matter if you find yourself wanting to
criticize or blame or getting
upset about something that you cannot
change think again and focus on the
positive aspect that you can get
from watching these videos and i think
the positive aspect is that
every single one of these polyglots has
something to offer they have different
motives different skill sets and
different life circumstances but is
at the end of the day up to you to
decide what you can make out of it
because
every individual is different and
all together if you can take the good
things from
every single politic even the ones you
dislike
even the ones whose style and motives
and philosophy you dislike
you can make a lot of progress so
thanks for watching i hope you like this
vlog style that's the second one
and hopefully there will be other ones
upon a request
have a fantastic day don't forget to if
you're new to this channel to subscribe
uh hit on the notification button for
more videos
and once again and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]
you